cbs news chief washington correspondent
major garrett joins us now he is also
the host of the take
out and the debrief podcast major good
morning we've heard now the president
admitting that he downplayed the virus
because he did not want to cause
panic what can you tell us about the
conversations
inside the white house early on
well the white house was struggling with
how serious
to talk to the american people about the
threat of coronavirus and the president
essentially said
it is serious but i'm going to convey
the thing i always convey
confidence and optimism in america go
back to march 7th when the president
went down to atlanta to tour the centers
for disease control and prevention he
said there
the doctors here keep telling me how do
you know so much about this maybe i have
a natural ability
essentially projecting to the country a
month after it already disclosed to bob
woodward
how serious he knew this virus was that
he knew everything that needed to be
known and it wasn't a big deal
what did that cost the country it cost
the country the ability to mobilize
and that that doesn't mean lockdowns
everywhere what that would have meant
is a serious national conversation about
the fundamentals
of containing the virus mask wearing
social distancing and
prioritizing which places should open
and which one should not
we did not have that conversation why
because it was lost in the president's
perpetual optimism
about where the virus was and where it
was going that he misread that
is an absolute fact and will be on the
ballot in november yeah and he continues
uh frequently not to wear masks one of
the presidents in in polling one of the
president's weakest issues
is in his response to the coronavirus
how is this likely now to affect the
campaign and his standing on that do you
think
in the campaign it resurrects
the pandemic as an issue for about two
and a half weeks now the president has
tilted the conversation redirected it to
law and order and what is the sense of
safety in america
now these revelations bring the pandemic
and all of its complications all of its
disruptions
right back front and center and that is
a place of vulnerability for this
president because lots of his
supporters know that he's optimistic and
strong true
but if that optimism and that strength
cost the country things that it wishes
it hadn't been cost
and imposed difficulties people are so
tired of
there's only one person to blame for
that the president united states and
that gives the biden campaign something
it hasn't had
in two and a half weeks a clear shot to
re
engage the conversation about what this
president did what he knew and most
importantly what he didn't say
about the pandemic so quickly major how
does the white house deal with the
fallout of this
move on that's all you can do as the
president said yesterday i didn't want
to create a panic i knew what i was
doing
i'm i'm the president united states i
made a decision and i'm going to live
with it everyone in this white house
knows
with donald trump there's a story the
next day and there's going to be one
today and there's going to be one
tomorrow and i'll just push through
all right major garrett thank you very
much